by the way dude i'm done with lakes okay  i'm not trying to be disrespectful lakes  are [ __ ] trash i don't listen i know  you may have a nice house on a lake and  it's great it's just the water's gross  it's [ __ ] there's people there just  sitting there drinking their [ __ ]  you'll see like a can of bud light float  by your [ __ ] pontoon boat it's just  i'm an ocean guy i like how you think  like the lakes are polluted but the  ocean isn't there's only a swirl of  trash two and a half times the size of  [ __ ] texas out there  the ocean dude go  [ __ ] there's monsters in there you guys  who swim in the ocean are out of your  [ __ ] minds because it's not just the  sharks  okay it's the currents and all that  every [ __ ] year some jackass gets  sucked out into the ocean and they never  see him again and just dies the slowest  most loneliest [ __ ] death  [ __ ] out of here with all of that